[Music]
Olympic opening ceremonies right here on
TBS oh wait a minute no they're not are
they what's to watch that crap I'm gonna
watch it Olympic opening ceremony sounds
actually pretty interesting
I'm they keep leaking all this
information about the opening ceremonies
and for example they're gonna have
British icons did you hear about this in
the opening ceremonies and it was just
reported I talked about this yesterday
that the ceremony is gonna feature an
epic showdown between Voldemort and Mary
Poppins yeah yeah then it's on to the
main event a fight to the death between
two of the Spice Girls I can't wait to
see that you like the real thing better
than the fake thing it's gonna be baby
and scary spice in a cage I don't even
remember is what I'm talking about
back come on their bag aren't they back
they're doing some sort of you know
Walker tour the Spice Girls or they're
touring with Walker Texas Ranger can I
have a little Voldemort again auntie I
love it
[Applause]
we should do a night where you just do
all the your voice the whole night is
moldable with this is gonna help you
from Warner Brothers what else is going
on oh it's been reported that the
opening ceremonies will also include a
video of James Bond and Queen Elizabeth
Julia the bad news is it's a sex video
why is that bad news kidding I've
watched that sure to help clean up
London before the Olympics they're
trying to clean up their image local
police have closed down over 80 brothels
yeah yeah apparently the brothels go
against the Olympic spirit of amateur
competition can't be a proud hour crowd
booed the closing of a brothel
let the [ __ ] do their work what's
wrong with you people a crowd turns on
that idea they're in favor of the job
creators exactly we're all getting to
know the athletes they're giving out a
lot of human interest stories about the
athletes we're knowing them as people I
saw this Holley Mangold a 350 pound
Olympic weight lifter says she's afraid
of plastic chairs that when asked for
comment plastic chair said not as afraid
as we are now the story there
the big story there is plastic chairs
can speak
it's the part I'm saying it's in and
they're they're horribly sexist horribly
sexist it's best we leave them alone
exactly eh all comments as Voldemort
from now on remember do we all next show
that's adding a chill to these
proceedings is it a hotel in England is
placing a copy of the book fifty Shades
of Grey in every room that's true yeah
yeah don't get excited though over there
Fifty Shades of Grey is the name of a
British cookbook
now some experts say that President
Obama's campaign may come down to the
Jewish voters in Florida that's what
they're saying his whole campaign they
come down to the Jewish voters in
Florida which explains why today Obama
announced his new running mate Barbara
Streisand
[Music]
that's my Barbara Streisand
Wow why is she doing this yeah yesterday
speaking of president bomber President
Obama gave a speech in Auckland hundreds
of people showed up to voice their
support for medical marijuana and by
showed up I mean wandered in for hours
late
[Applause]